the kremlin is fighting its war against
ukraine on the battlefield on tv and
online and russians are not being told
what's really happening president putin
and his government have made it a crime
to criticize the conflict or even report
the truth experts say his lies are meant
to maintain public support and make
trouble for democracies holly williams
has more
ukraine this is the russian media's
version of atrocities committed by
russian forces in ukraine
was perpetrated by ukrainian forces
it's not surprising russia brought in
new laws last month making it a criminal
offence to report anything that
contradicts the government's version of
events about the invasion
and while some russians have risked
arrest to protest against the war
vladimir putin's approval rating went up
to 83 percent after the invasion
according to one poll
[Applause]
this russian man says ukraine should be
wiped off the face of the earth and
poland could be next
we'll take this land for ourselves says
this woman it used to be that way before
russia's outlandish claims that these
videos were somehow staged
or carried out by ukrainians were
quickly debunked including with
satellite images if you're repeating the
propaganda of the russian government and
president putin you're on the wrong side
of history but it has been repeated on
social media planting seeds of doubt in
the minds of some outside of russia
they're trying to create a degree of
uncertainty right samuel ramani is an
expert on russian foreign policy who
told us it's classic russian
disinformation so they're trying to
enable like anti-establishment voices in
the in the far left and the far right
about an alternative version of events
they've been stoking these uh
conspiracies amongst those groups for
years and they're also trying to erode
more indirectly public trust in
government institutions liberal
democracy and the media
the u.s has been warning about russian
lies since before the invasion including
unfounded accusations that ukraine is
committing genocide this is straight out
of the russian playbook
and they're not fooling us
even vladimir putin's justification for
his war is disinformation
this month he doubled down on his claim
that he's trying to rid ukraine of nazis
despite the fact that president vladimir
zelinsky is jewish and he repeated the
allegation that russian atrocities were
somehow faked
the most powerful weapon against russian
lies may come from ukraine itself
it's shot a light on the horrors of
russia's attacks the bbc uncovers
evidence given journalists wide-ranging
access to the conflict zone
this is more than just a collection of
terrible deaths
president zielenski showed graphic
videos while demanding justice at the
united nations and has demanded more
weapons from the west
he's a master communicator a master
persuader he can uh even in a dark
moment or crisis like this
bring in humor bring in relatability and
kind of just you know kind of
rally international opinion quite
effectively so the russians are are
losing the information war in part
because of
zolensky's prowess at that alongside
russia's brutal invasion of ukraine
there's a war being fought against
disinformation pitching a young
democracy against an
authoritarian-minded regime
for cbs morning's holly williams ukraine
always the physical war and then also
that information war holly williams for
us holly thank you